bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
hoy los llevaremos a italia
miembros de la mafia calabresa ndragheta
una de las más poderosas del mundo
fueron juzgados a principios del 2021 es
el juicio más grande contra el crimen
organizado que se lleva a cabo en italia
desde el de la mafia siciliana cosa
nostra a fines de la década de los 80s
en noviembre se dictaron unas 70
condenas y todavía quedan por juzgar
355 acusados esta organización mafiosa
que nació con el robo de ganado la
extorsión y los secuestros ha levantado
un imperio de la droga del juego del
azar y de la corrupción en las
licitaciones públicas que según las
autoridades italianas arroja unos
beneficios en torno a 50 mil millones de
euros cada año
las periodistas luís malo a natalia
mendoza y charlotte daban conocieron
algunos protagonistas cercanos a este
llamado maxi juicio en el que muchos
italianos del sur están depositando sus
esperanzas para que disminuye el crimen
organizado en la región aquí la historia
[Música]
el fiscal nicola gratteri es uno de los
hombres más amenazados de italia incluso
cuando camina por los pasillos del
palacio de justicia no da un paso sin
sus guardaespaldas
y aviso como la y ustedes le avisan a
los demás
ok asignado para las 15
adiós presidente hasta luego chau él
representa al estado desde hace casi un
año en el megaproceso contra la bragueta
la mafia calabresa el grupo criminal más
poderoso de italia y vosotros cortes de
vivo escoltado desde 1986
estos últimos años han aumentado los
riesgos siendo fiscal trato ir cada vez
más lejos mis investigaciones son más
profundas y la presión suben y ccoo
tuvimos que reforzar mi protección en
mis desplazamientos están cada vez más
de marcados que controló durante hiper
force y
en su oficina están los rostros de los
jueces falcone y borsellino
asesinados por la mafia siciliana hace
30 años objetivo de un nuevo atentado
estado en judith paolo borsellino
varias veces a la semana el fiscal se
dirige hacia el gran juicio en su
vehículo blindado
desafortunadamente su participación
expone a toda su familia que también ha
recibido amenazas
de uno de mis hijos anda en moto
y su plan era matarlo simulando una
salida hacerlo parecer como un accidente
para asesinarlo
este proyecto de atentado o el ior no
fue revelado por uno de los acusados del
proceso en este tribunal improvisado
el edificio industrial está protegido
por el ejército la sala de audiencia fue
acondicionada como un inmenso salón de
conferencias para este proceso
monumental
estable grande
esta sala de tres mil 300 metros
cuadrados hay mil puestos para sentarse
los acusados no están aquí nos vemos a
través de estas pantallas hablan por
videoconferencia directamente desde su
cárcel es del útil en una no hacer venir
aquí a todos esos acusados durante el
año costaría 50 millones de euros y se
necesitarían diez mil policías y agentes
penitenciarios para protegerlos y
trasladarlos
este juicio es histórico más de 350
acusados tran que está no se habla las
bases de las mafias son estructuras
familiares muy secretas así que obtener
confesiones es una proeza encuesta
proyección no para ante acuerdo hay 42
arrepentidos que están colaborando con
la justicia en este proceso reunimos a
todos los detenidos a los más
importantes que hablan
que pueden dar información sobre la gran
que está pero también conocen hechos de
crímenes precisos e información sobre
los acusados
imputada te digo esto creo que esto
estos testimonios son un gran golpe para
la mafia más poderosa de italia para
llegar hasta aquí fueron necesarios más
de tres años de investigación en el
cuartel de vivo valència los carabineros
han trabajado sin descanso día y noche
centro de género ni
[__] calmo cuando todo está así de
calmado hay que tener mucho talento para
entender lo que se está tramando eso es
lo difícil de trabajar en este
territorio siempre tratamos de ir un
paso adelante
soportaron largas horas de vigilancia
haciendo seguimientos discretos y
examinando conversaciones telefónicas
hasta lograr esta gran redada a finales
de 2019 la operación reina chica scott
logró 336 detenciones el capitán
alessandro hui dirige el polo de las
investigaciones se acuerda del arresto
de domenico bonavota después de dos años
de fuga no nos quedamos más de cinco
minutos ok no debemos llamar la atención
la noche de su arresto rodeamos esta
casa cuando entramos encontramos a
muchas otras personas se podría decir
que eran cómplices para encubrirlo
la suárez él estaba escondido debajo de
la cama costos hoteles
el hombre que se escondía debajo de una
cama está acusado de homicidios
tentativas de homicidio y extorsión
responde a estos cargos delante del
tribunal y enfrenta a las víctimas
la vida de carmín y tapia un simple
comerciante se transformó desde que
empezó a participar en el juicio como
testigo ahora no puede salir sin sus dos
escoltas
solo hoy de mi casa al trabajo vale la
pena la situación tenía que cambiar
implica sacrificios pero son necesarios
me estoy adaptando a mis nuevas
limitaciones al igual que la mayoría de
los comerciantes de mi cotera el
estanquero fue sometido al piso en
impuestos que la mafia impone para tener
derecho a abrir el local
y sí
tenía que pagar quince mil euros cada
tres meses pero cuando pague la primera
cuota me dijeron que no era suficiente
ni siquiera para asegurar el alquiler
así que entendí que sería una historia
sin fin seguir pagando hasta no tener un
centavo ni siquiera quedaban cigarrillos
aquí
cada mañana las amenazas se volvían más
preocupantes cuando llegó el punto de la
asfixia financiera
el comerciante decidió ir a denunciar a
sus extorsionistas donde después de mi
denuncia los carabineros empezaron a
investigar y dos meses después los
arrestaron
por haberse opuesto al clan local
carmine essap ya perdió muchos clientes
le reconocemos haber sido tan valiente
porque no es fácil lo que hizo
logra un señor sapiens
[Música]
la
denuncia fue por chantaje
[Música]
extorsión para contar con apoyo en su
lucha carmines up ya le pidió ayuda a
una asociación antimafia las personas de
islam
[Música]
son muchos los que están sometidos al
jefe de la dra nieta
entonces tratan de excluir te y eso va a
seguir a menudo después de la denuncia
hay que pagar otro precio el del
aislamiento
al igual que camine cerca de dos
millones de calabreses viven bajo la
influencia de la gran que está alrededor
de 150 clanes 150 andrín es comparten
este territorio
luigi mancuso encabeza al clan más
poderoso
es el principal acusado del proceso
obtuvo el poder gracias a su papel en la
construcción del puerto de gioia tauro
[Música]
en ese puerto desembarcan siete mil
contenedores al día es un punto
estratégico para la banqueta
que ocupa el primer lugar en el tráfico
de cocaína
en italia a través de los puertos
europeos nosotros somos el que incauta
la mayor cantidad de cocaína porque
estamos hablando de toneladas no de
kilos en 2020 nuestra oficina confiscó
alrededor de 7 toneladas de cocaína el
estrato kirk acepta en torno la técnico
que los cargamentos llegan de américa
del sur asia áfrica de todas partes del
mundo
ok muchachos ya puede venir el
contenedor
solo unos 40 contenedores son
inspeccionados
i
los goles por aquí vamos a mirar allá
según una fuente policial tan sólo entre
el 10 y el 15 por ciento de la droga
importada es interceptado ok ok está
bien nos vamos
a menudo utilizan la propia estructura
del contenedor a veces puede haber
huecos fisuras pueden estar tapadas con
distintos tipos de mercancías de origen
ilícito
es como buscar una aguja en un pajar
pero cuando la encontramos es una gran
captura
pero cuando si pies casi pies kpn
entre las últimas redadas se encontraron
estos cuatro costales adentro había 108
kilos de cocaína un botín calculado en
22 millones de euros
una pérdida ínfima frente al volumen de
negocios anual del gran dieta que
asciende a 43 mil millones de euros son
sumas que despiertan los apetitos y
avivan las guerras entre clanes
sanguinarios el recuerdo del hijo de
martin noche era bolo está en cada una
de las paredes de su casa su cuarto se
convirtió en un santuario
aquí guardamos el tiquete de tren que
filippo había comprado para ir a ver a
pescar a ver un partido de la lluvia la
tragedia ocurrió el jueves 25 el debía
irse el sábado a pescar pero nunca se
fue
además el 25 de octubre de 2012 en la
noche filippo chera voló se despidió de
su novia para regresar a su casa
haciendo autostop se subió en el carro
equivocado el de un mafioso atrapado en
medio de una guerra de clanes
su objetivo era domenico tazón le
dispararon pero filipe recibió los tiros
aquí aquí y aquí tenía 35 fracturas
estos tipos destruyeron nuestra vida
el estado italiano reconoció a filippo
como víctima inocente de la mafia le
hicieron un monumento en su pueblo
para mí eso lo representa todo es un
símbolo para los jóvenes y además es
sobre todo un símbolo para que los
jóvenes crezcan en una cultura diferente
lejos de la criminalidad que hay en
nuestros pueblos la investigación sobre
la muerte de su hijo se archivó en 2016
sin haber identificado a los autores de
los disparos martino espera que ahora en
el marco del mega proceso los
arrepentidos puedan aportar
informaciones nuevas nos reunimos con
uno de ellos luigi bonaventura no verán
su rostro su dirección es confidencial a
cientos de kilómetros de calabria
si regreso a calabria soy un hombre
muerto si regreso a calabria the war
marm o hacerme matar
ha estado familiarizado con este clima
de violencia desde que era muy joven
uno crece entre armamento y hay que
tomarlas cargarlas descargarlas mirar
por el visor disparar se vuelve un juego
nacido en una familia de jefes de gran
que estás fue educado para matar a los
20 años cometió su primer asesinato
luego acumuló crímenes pero al
convertirse en padre maduro la idea de
arrepentirse
quería decírselo a mi padre para evitar
ser considerado un traidor sabía que
estaba ocurriendo muchas opciones pero
quería que lo supiera por mí y no por
alguien más le expliqué la situación y
anuncie que quería darle un futuro
diferente a mis hijos que no dependieran
de nadie y que la gran guetta no tuviera
poder de decisión sobre lo que llegarían
a ser mis hijos
y estoy con de arriba
sus decisiones significó amenazas de
muerte su propio padre trató de matarlo
ahora el ex mafioso le entrega a la
justicia su conocimiento sobre la
organización
[Aplausos]
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]